[Music]
in 12-hour traffic jam news submitted by
queen of the north season 5 dude how
many times to tell you this [ __ ]
sorry oh it's okay this fall already
spoiled the Game of Thrones to me Andy
yeah
I'm not gonna wait for some next person
who's watching them it's too late wait
why are you still on season 5 I know I
know we've been busy that's your fault
wait wait he's why he's barely watching
like [ __ ] for cuz he's thinking about
your life to Saturday night I could have
been wrong about it now I got it
and you think crying all weekend I'll
put it together a couple of faked a
hostage situation in a 12-hour standoff
with police
what the [ __ ] [ __ ] what is it like so
it's a really crazy story that's
happening in Wisconsin
I know [ __ ] went down in Wisconsin
usually dollars ways that we're making a
murders that that's what the Packers are
nothing else that was Arizona do they
hold like an apple tree hosta what did
you think making a murderer
I thought you said Breaking Bad like I
registered briefing hall at all I made
that mistake to the other day it's New
Mexico okay anyway so this thing here it
it was really crazy so this couple who
have a very toxic relationship they were
on their way to go sell some drugs okay
as a couple is you know just you so this
girl her name is Caitlin she is an
escort and one of her clients owed her a
thousand dollars okay so she and her
boyfriend used they were planning to use
this van to drive to this other place to
sell half an ounce of cocaine six to
fourteen grams of heroin and roll
smaller amount of men they're
entrepreneurs yeah I mean apparently
she's a mom but I don't know how many
kids she had any any amount is too many
at this point this guy did did he have
like a [ __ ] tab or something that he
racked up like hey like thousand bucks
it's like she kind of dumb for just
accepting it on credit how much are
[ __ ] on the street she's the closest
one that worked in a sex industry who
were you a waitress at a strip club or
something
hooters I was a waitress at nah I was at
yeah I was a okay so you know it strip
clubs they have the kind of like the
host girls that like wait strip club
like yeah but I do that for like two
weeks parties at Hooters I've never had
a show that's party at Hooters with
horny dads and unaware moms dude we're
mom's aware of what Hooters is yes the
wings are pretty good scantily clad I
was way more I was showing way more when
I worked up the strip club for two weeks
Wow cuz I had a bustier it was like just
pushing up these tiny little titties and
then I had these tiny little underwear
and my bow is hanging out gosh why did
why was that only two weeks cuz I didn't
want to be there it was gross
some guy kept giving me like
hundred-dollar bills but asking me if I
would come with him after and I felt so
like rapey that's so much money what do
you give me the money for it just
talking to me like you wanna he was just
kind of like do you want to like go with
me like that like hundred dollar alright
your dollar okay let's do it
I would you just keep leading him on
so I did but then I didn't want to go
back because I was like this guy's gonna
[ __ ] murder me later
no I didn't have the confidence to know
he's keeping a tab in his head he's like
I think this chick 2 grand like this
chick right here cab this lady right
here kept $1,000 tab in her head row and
stole van yep so he was killing right
and then nathan is the boyfriend so they
were pulled over by a cop and that's
when things just got ugly really fast Oh
apparently they were living in this
stolen van and they parked in a state
forest probably got a stinking [ __ ]
problem Rikki I mean you could hold it
all day I hope you use baby wipes or
something necessary details don't you
connect that that makes sense yeah she's
wording showers she's not doing a
[ __ ] [ __ ] bathing face I'll be
honest when the story started I thought
she had a fairly clean [ __ ] the logic
is so sound I now in convinced
information can you imagine this [ __ ]
is like Rambo with two guns like I'm
gonna get my thousand dollars that's the
last time I saw that [ __ ] dick
and then there's like all these drugs in
the back but it's all like there's also
baby toys in the [ __ ] sleeping bag
and there's like a [ __ ] basketball
bouncing around while they're like on
their way like the a-team to go they're
like [ __ ] this [ __ ] right and
then Diggle and in a cop's Topsham villa
oh [ __ ] while she's got the stinkiest
[ __ ] on her just surround it all off
yeah thank you for setting the [ __ ]
scene so I could smell that [ __ ] dude
thank you yes smell-o-vision will be a
thing in the future yeah so then that's
when the cop came over and he walked up
to them and ordered them to get out of
the car but instead of getting out they
drove away as one does hitting a
five-mile police chase that ended when
officers threw down a spike strip that
stopped no man yep so when the van
stopped the couple began hanging up
sheets and tapestries to isolate
themselves that's how they've reported
in the back in the forest you know
probably in the van
chased by cops highway so after five
hours of negotiations that's when police
fired tear gas into the van earlier well
they did it because she was saying that
that they had a baby in Oh smart she's
pretty smart yeah and so during this
whole time they she started
live-streaming on Facebook because so
this dude Nathan right he kept saying
like so he had a gun and he kept saying
like ah they're not taking me alive and
you're gonna come with me putting the
gun on her head [ __ ] so she was the
life's doing it because she was like you
know like people like record those
people like if some [ __ ] happens at
least this is being recorded and it was
also so to record the police and their
interactions with them cuz she like
didn't feel she didn't feel safe
obviously just turn yourself in [ __ ]
get out of their car she's scared to get
out of the car cuz he might kill her
right no that was fate yeah you're not
worried about that oh he's making it up
yeah I wonder how the cops
well they probably watch the livestream
yeah they're just like always not gonna
be with tear gas in this [ __ ] yeah how
long did they wait like five hours or 12
hours how did they finally realize that
they were live-streaming know that
there's no baby and then they could just
come up in maybe from the livestream
yeah so I was thinking like maybe from
that or maybe they got like that heat
[ __ ] like that [ __ ] you know that
[ __ ] thing that you look inside there
like there's only two [ __ ] in
there that's true thermal goggles I
think mm-hmm yes so nathan has a lengthy
criminal record and had a warrant out
for his arrest surprise he was like I am
NOT going back to prison without a fight
usually when they're desperate like that
yo then it's their last straw [ __ ]
born to lose [ __ ] yeah so the next she
was telling the people watching the
stream that they have a love-hate
relationship that she would do anything
for him but he forces her to do things
and that she's never done anything wrong
and then she did it all for
and then everyone who's watching a live
stream he's like get off the highway I'm
trying to get somewhere babe do they
have to shut down the highway true
that's the [ __ ] that this is not the
most right I mean can you do it in like
the desert where there's no one really
there and then like where it doesn't
bother people communions people have
your meltdown somewhere else yeah like
drive far out I like away from traffic
especially during rush hour to or until
like a Walmart parking lot or something
there's a lot of space there dude this
morning on my way here but not on the
weekend cop we're in the middle of a
traffic jam and a cop pulls somebody
over there in the fast lane so the
person has to go across every single
lane and then they park on the side but
the side is like part of the street so
it's like dude do you have to do this
here you just [ __ ] all of us we're
gonna [ __ ] now is it wrong cuz I don't
know about in California but in Texas I
always just like put my blinker on and I
like go on the highway until I can exit
completely exit and then go somewhere
safe I don't know if here are they gonna
start thinking that you're running from
the cops because y'all have a lot of
like maintain like a reasonable speed
that's considered as [ __ ] I don't want
to like wind up on the news like I'm
just trying to get off the freeway
exactly see that's nice cops don't they
don't you to get off there'll be times
when I do pull over and they're like
just exit because I mean they don't
wanna get out of the car yeah they get
out they could get hit boom well this
cop didn't care man he was down for the
extra traffic I'll tell you that so what
ended up happening is that the cops shot
Nathan three times I don't know where
Wow but as of right now what they're
reporting is that the police report the
sheriff's department won't give the the
lawyer Nathan's lawyer any information
about whether or not he's alive where
he's being held because there is no
reports of him being held like he's not
a nut jail inmate list and he's also
they're also saying that the medical
examiner's office had no record of
Nathan Chapman and they're saying that
at the hospital where he could have
possibly been there is no record of this
guy either so they just don't know like
the lawyer doesn't know where the [ __ ]
he went you turn into a reptile and
slithered away
we go video it's an alien so the girl
Kaelin she has been charged with six
felonies including bail-jumping fleeing
police and striking a police animal all
because I forgot to mention she's
stabbed
oh the canine like a dog like the police
until now she was fine biting her up but
luckily the dog is okay
the dog was treated and released you
should go to jail because that's
assaulting a police officer
hey striking a police animal using a
dangerous weapon do when those dogs get
badges and like we bestow you the
highest on a police officer
ya know she looks like she's filled on
[ __ ] a bad day this is John Belushi oh
yes yeah she looks like really bad what
if I look like that engineers if you're
not doing math I think you'll go nowhere
near that man thing can be kinda hot
honestly example the chicken that
[ __ ] music group and they kind of
have like that Matthew look and you got
a narrow it down for me my list of music
groups okay the American pop source with
the da think D goes oh remember it
remember couple years ago when the nude
Jared Leto Joker was shown and that and
they were copying that band that's the
band no clue they were copying the look
at that band with his [ __ ] tattoos no
idea okay
Australian chick yes tappy tappy Oh D at
worth yes
she's not methi I was just saying that
it's a car semi ever saw her I had a
nightmare of her like she scared you
scary she's looking that guys definitely
messy as [ __ ] so her standing next to
him I mean they look away worst India
she's a reptilian I also know the
backstory for this yeah and there's a
lot of there's a lot of things like if
there was no backstory you'd be like I
just not having a good day like if you
just like cropped out that if maybe if
it wasn't a mugshot you got a thing like
maybe I'd be like everyone looks pretty
bad in a mug shot
I think dream like January Jones without
makeup that's Jay look like white trash
to me she could be pretty attractive I
think she could clean up she looks
symmetrical very much yeah very that's
why I was like that looks like me and
didn't you know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]